this is a production of cornell
university
yeah thanks adam for the nice
introduction and also great invitation
it is really a
great pleasure to visit camille and see
many
good friends and see greg for many years
we met when i was a
first year graduate student back in
kansas so it's really impressive visit
this morning to see many of you so today
i'm going to present some of work after
i learned my
job in
texas
so i
titled my work on the non-self
recognition and signaling mechanism
implant in native immunity
the fact is
although we seemingly
live in a very peaceful wonderful world
but in fact we are surrounded by all
kinds of enemies it's a dangerous world
right so bacteria from the virus is an
insect and the fact is we are housing
most of time and resistance is the rule
disease is rather uh inception this is
in large attributed
by the robust innate immune system
so at the heart of the immune system is
the individual capacity to recognize
itself versus non-self to elicit the
defense response so the key to a healthy
immune system is its ability to
distinguish between the body's own cells
and recognize lung as itself and foreign
cells as
non-self
so this echoes a famous saying i learned
one when i was a elementary school
student from
uh
famous chinese philosopher so knowing
your enemy and yourself you can fight
without defeat
so
compare with the animals
plants even more vulnerable they are
excessive when they get sick no way to
talk to doctors to get rescued right
they also don't have the adaptive immune
system as the animal system and they
also don't have the specialized
somatic immune cells and what we share
is this robust infinity immune system
so the inlet immune system implants has
been classified as a two-tiered defense
system
the perception of cells
surf i mean perception of microbial
components by cell surface receptor
triggered the first line of defense
response also terms as prr patent
triggered immunity for scientists pti
so those microbial components
collectively they work hard termed as
pamp or mams stands for pathogen or
associated molecular patterns
and testing infections also often
trigger damage to the host cell which
generate endogenous damage associated
molecular patterns
so collectively those things can be
perceived by the cell surface pattern
recognition receptors
so in plants what is striking is we know
those
microbial components are perceived by
receptive light protein on receptor like
kinase and implants there are up to
several hundreds of these kind of
proteins in contrast animals for
instance human up to 10 tlr proteins
perceiving those microbial components
so this may provide sorts of
uh
for plant cell civilian system to
recognize all different kind of
microbial components to provide this
fundamental basal defense response
so upon perception of microbial
components plants trigger complicated
signaling pathways so those signaling
cascade has been classified as
two-tiered one is eti and the other one
is pti pti mainly needed by cell surface
receptor where eti is moving through the
intracellular receptors
so today i'm going to present some of
our work in the context of known
knowledge in pta signaling and
demonstrate uh to uh up to now
how we think those
pumps are perceived by the receptors how
the signaling were transduced after the
head counter nucleus to activate
immuting or defense-related gene
expression
so
the one of for
well-studied pump is from bacteria
derived flatly
so bacteria use this motor engine
platelet to swim around is an essential
component for bacteria its major protein
consists of flatulence and some of for
part of flattening protein can be
recognized
by the host for instance the 22 animal
acid peptide corresponding to a
n-terminal region of phlegm could be
recognized
by
artopsis receptor fs2 which
which encode a leucine-rich repeat
receptor-like kinase
so
upon the flattening perception of
electron d2 perception fs2 protein
quickly almost instantaneously assumes
it with another rk similar like fs2
called back one from a complex so recent
structure study also demonstrates both
fs2 back one
kind of mediating the recognition of
bacterial fluidity trigger downstream
sibling events
so upon the bacterial flattening
recognition a series of immune response
can be detected
by various ways for instance the rapid
activation of evolutionary conserved
magnets signaling cascade by this
uh
markings antibody western blotting our
defense related immuting activation by
rdpcr other
redux
changes for instance the reactive oxy
species production as early as a few
minutes and also later you could observe
a catalyst deposition which liquid
further liquidify the cell wall to
protect the cell from further infection
and also prolong the treatment of
flattening of the flag 22 peptide
incubate the adoptive seedling growth
likely caused by constituted activation
of
defense response and also pre-treatment
of this lightening of like 22 peptide
protect the plants from the further
secondary infection
of the burdens pathogen
so
one
perspective we examined in order to
understand how flexible trigger immunity
is transduced is looking at the uh
phospho-proteomic dynamics and
transcriptional
changes are conflicted to treatment
through these two
serious efforts we found one small
kindness
called originally called borderless
induced kinase big one which encodes a
result of cytoplasmic kinase
could be quickly phosphorylated
by upon fluctuating treatment
as shown in this western blotting the
bench kind of migration got delayed
later we did a serious experiment to
demonstrate this indeed it's a
phosphorylation event for instance
treating the sample with phosphorus cip
could block this band shift
so indicating this protein is responding
to flex 22 treatment
and this is small protein although
encoder cytosolic
receptor like kinase but it has a
puritan uh mercedes motif it's target to
the plasma membrane and the alpha
reflecting d2 receptor fs2 and black one
also a plasma membrane localized protein
then we further exempt whether they tend
to physically associate to each other so
this is a co-immuno precipitation i say
you could see big one formal complex
with fs2 and back one without the light
and perception
suggesting the form of pre-existing
complex and interestingly a conflicting
rule treatment seems like the big one
got released from the
fs2 and back one complex
and big both bitcoin back one and fs2
encodes
kinases so we further ask whether there
are any
phosphorylation events occurs within the
complex here suits you actually
from india
kinase acid you could see actually back
one could strongly phosphorylate big one
and we further mapped the major
phosphorylation side if you rotate this
side you largely compromise the
phosphorylation events and also
we demonstrate in addition backward
phosphorus big one bitcoin also
transforms from the back
to back one to further enhance the
kinase activity of
back one
and so for plant our k family has been
classified
as serving swinging kinases
so along with our uh phosphate i mean
the identification of phosphorylation
size of big one we find actually big one
has multiple sides is phosphorylated and
teres inside
and then we mutate some teres inside and
find one of the terrorists inside is
particularly important to mediating the
kindness activity for both
syringe learning
activity and the tyrosine active and the
total kindness activity but some side is
specifically required for a tyrosine
activity not for serving surrounding
kinase activity and we further asked
whether those tyrosine phosphorylation
residues are required for bitcoin
functioning in
defense response you could see mutation
of those teres inside
no longer able to complement the big one
mutant phenotype as the y-type big one
in terms of baltimore's infection and
the loss of production so suggesting
those stars inside is important
for bitcoin function
and
along with the recent study
for back one actually from steven uh
steven uh groups they demonstrate
background also potentially carry auto
parasitic phosphorylation activity we
further find actually bitcoin
phosphorylation tyrosine site is
mediated by back one directly so
this research is suggesting rk complex
tyrosine phosphorylation maybe it's a
prevalent event rather than
previously predicted mainly needed by
surrendering kinases
activity
so
as i mentioned uh early so after flight
22 perception fs2 from a complex with
the back one back one originally was
identified as a
for
private and receptor associated kinase
so bipolar form complex with ryun play
important role in diameter growth
regulation
so our research demonstrates big when
the small kinase function as a direct
substrate of backward
then recent study also demonstrates
there is a
i mean extensive crosstalk between vr
signaling and fs2 signaling although the
mechanism is still not clear we know the
vr mediated
signaling activation unidirectionally
suppress the fs2 thickening and multiple
steps
so then we asked what kind of whether
our work and raw bitcoin play in their
military signing transaction
so to our surprise
so big one
in contrast
as back one play a negative role in vr
sitting as you can see this is a typical
vr response essay
unlike her backward big one is
insensitive even hypersensitive to brg
which is a vr biosynthesis inhibitor
and similarly the uh
in terms of the response to best one
which is a
key trans transcription factor in vr
signaling once the br signaling is on
this
transcription factor is dephosphorylated
as shown from the migration shift from
the western blood
and you can see in big one mutant both
the basal level
and upon bl treatment the baseline the
phosphorylated form increased so this
also
i mean consistent with this brg
treatment result big one has
piqua mutant has elevated vr signaling
going on
and similarly the
bl suppressed gene is further suppressed
in the bitcoin mutant and we further
crossed the big one to the private
mutant you could see bitcoin
elevated the growth defect of private
br receptor phenotype so genetically
suggests indeed bitcoin clay loads and
function downstream of primal
and we further explored potential
mechanisms why bitcoin plays such kind
of law in vr singling and similar as fs2
and private also encode uh our
appropriate receptor line kinase
and sitting on the plasma membrane here
the core ip i see you you could see
because also
associated with brigham
from a pre-existing complex
intrinsically upon their treatment
equine also is released from paraban
complex this is strictly similar as the
complex dynamics of big one with fs2 in
pdi sigma although big one played
different role in tdi is a positive
regulator but in a vr pathway it's a
negative regulator
and this
definition
further confirm the association of big
one and the brigham
and we also know ryung is a strong
kindness we ask whether
there are any trans-phosphorylation
events between prion and bitcoin as you
can see from the muscle kinase i say
actually private strongly phosphorylate
the big one even stronger than
phosphorylation towards the back one
this is the initial study of for private
and background phosphorylation mediating
the
vr signaling and then intensely upon bl
treatment it seems like a private
towards bitcoin is further intense
so suggesting up on bl treatment there
is an enhancement of
problem phosphorylation towards big one
then we further ask the consequence of
the phosphorylation between these two
components
as you can see here
either neither the big one pines mutant
are bright one kinase mutant which both
i mean both of them
lost the kindness activity you could see
let's do from complex the big one
chinese mutants still from contacts with
brigham and the same thing for private
chinese mutants with big ones
however live no longer
released
from the complex
so the
seems like the complex become very tight
if there is no phosphorylation events
suggesting the phosphorylation between
private and bitcoin maybe it's required
for this complex
i mean
required for dissociation of big one
from the brevan complex
so through this research we demonstrate
that this big one play negative role in
vr signaling through directory
phosphorylation of
private towards big one and somehow
negatively regulate br media development
and growth however big one directly
phosphorylated by back one meaning
positively regulating the pti response
so we don't know exactly how this
distinct
very likely is distinct phosphorylation
coming from back one from private
dictating such kind of
different outputs we are making the
differential phosphorylation for equine
through
upstream of kinase to further address
this phenomenon and another perspective
we explore fs2 signaling is based on the
observation actually back one as i said
formal complex with fs2 also from
complex with bright one recent several
years we found actually that one also is
required for additional
other needed path immediate responses
including back one from direct complex
with efr which recognizes bacterial eftu
pump
and also
formal complex with damp receptor type
r112 so we are thinking so any component
associated with spectrum potentially can
serve as a convergent point to further
mediating the pti response so we look
for the background associated protein
through this line of research one
particular protein we focus
uh is the plant you box containing e3
life is called a part a particular part
of
the 12 and 13. you can see in the east
200 black one and top 13 directly
incorrect as so in the whole ip i see
and unlike
the
so the background and the power certain
interaction is constitutive without
lightning already from a complex
however the
seems like the path 13 associated with
fs2 only upon the light and perception
and this complex for formation occurs
extremely fast as early as a couple of
seconds we could see by co-ip experiment
fs2 pub certain formal complex
so this
third has suggest maybe this part is
reliable
associated with back one upon light and
perception of
fs2 so somehow we quickly form a
complex
then the tab in closer e3 like this we
ask
whether
this is reliance does anything to do
with the component in the complex we
performed the virtual ubiquitination i
see to our surprise
the pop 13 directly ubiquitinated
the flight 22 flattening receptor fs2 as
you can see from this geode ladder
formation
however it did not you'll be putting
into the code receptor background or big
one so this may also suggest the signal
specificity as this one is the primary
receptor for phlegm the other can look
like a non-polytrophic rule in multiple
sibling events
and we also know ubiquitination of
protein can need it either for protein
degradation or standard protein for
us
for cycling to activate the signaling
then we further ask what's the
consequence of this israelites needed
ubiquitination
here you can see with prolonged flight
22 treatment
the receptor effects to underwent the
degradation
however in the past mutant that
particularly in a double mutant such
kind of degradation is largely reduced
so suggesting genetically i mean
providing genetic evidence part 12 13
immediate ubiquitin nation on fs2 likely
it's mediating fs2 degradation
and the genetic analysis of paper mutant
further suggests
our i mean support our hypothesis you
can see in the power of mutant the flat
22 induced the pilot's deportation is
further elevated compared with y-type
similar
for disease resistance the top power
mutant is small resistance
uh compared with y-type so suggesting
probably a negative role in a pti
response
then this power protein is called uh
modular protein so has a n-terminal and
carburized but a plant-specific domain
and then in the middle is the u-box
domain and then c-terminal has an armed
law repeats
and we further did a serious deletion
mutational analysis to narrow down
actually this amadino repeat is
mediating the specific interaction
directory interaction with back one
and also phosphorylation mainly occurs
on the angular repeat
by backward and then the uv proteination
towards the substrate fs2 mainly
mediated by the u-box domain
then we hypothesize whether
we by generating the armadillo repeat
domain alone will generate a dominant
negative version of this issue like this
will block the excess of the
substrate could generate the dominant
negative worth of the
parts
so we generate the transmittance of all
expression
alone
transgenic plants you could see these
transient plants behave similar
as the pub
mutant particular it reached to the
seminal level as the double mutant so
the transgenic plants become more
resistant
to
bacterial plastic infection and loss
production and also you could see from
the kinase activation the powerful
single mutant or the double mutant show
more
mechanics activation compared with wild
type basically the trenching plants
similar as the
double mutant so suggesting these power
all expression armed
alone could provide a dominant dominant
negative effect the reason we do this is
it's a challenge to study the individual
function of the part
because of the redundancy this is a
large gym family so by doing such kind
of dominating thing we wish we could
further elucidate additional members of
poverty and families function
in immunity and other
process
so
with this line of research it seems like
the once the defense response is
activated the cell has a mechanism by
recruiting the e3 ligase into the
receptor complex and then quickly
degrade the receptor to down regulate
the immune response when it is no longer
needed right so to keep the defense
response
uh tightly
under control so this again
equals a famous saying
i learned from
elementary school from the same person
so there is no instance for any country
benefiting from a constant defense
process right so at the right time we
should stop
such kind of
things to to benefit the society in the
long run so stop the war we should get
support from government for research
so meanwhile i also will
this line of research
although we and the plants look
definitely
i mean different my daughter at
my school knows or you are a fit doctor
although you work at a house general
hospital you are not a true doctor you
work with plans it's different but i'm
trying to tell her what i do is really
important for real doctors because you
see what i found is models similar as
what happened
to us
we as a human and plants we all
use
a similar type of protein those
receptors i mean receptor proteins sit
on the plasma membrane our boxes use
this fs2 and human use pr4 for lps tlr5
for flattening
and then the downstream
for activation of the signaling cascade
for human we have the iraq site of
kinase and then the similar type of
kinase big one black one transduced fs2
thickening and then we further found the
israelites monitor the defense uh
i mean latitude by israelites working on
this receptor part and similarly in
human we have trust three exactly same
looking easter bunnies or countries to
transform to monitor the defense
response
and in addition in human develop another
type of history like this and monitor
this iraq
kindness to finding the
immune response recently
we found actually there are similar type
of history like this also working at
this level so i tell her how important
we are so
so this is uh
we are taking the proteomic approach to
look at
at the genome-wide level how the
impregnation potentially regulating the
pti response so what we did is to purify
the ubiquitin nation associated protein
and then to mass spec and to identify
such kind of protein to our surprise out
of our list
from the receptor to rck to the my
kindness level to the transcription
transcription factor level those known
components are
on
our list so
at multiple levels defense response are
tightly checked by such kind of
mechanism shared in human and implants
where in the process particularly
interesting for this this person you see
the utility nation this jail as long as
you can see signal indicating your
reputation events so you could see this
protein is
specifically induced upon like 22
treatment so we are in the process to
further characterizing
what's the e3 like this involved what's
the consequence to monitor this protein
for your detonation process
and
another approach we took to understand
the pti signaling is
the classical genetic approach
to looking for
additional components involving tti so
we
the philosophy is we use the early
pti marketing as a result so here we
choose ifrk1 so-called which in code of
lightning induced the receptor highness
one so this gene
can be induced by flanking shoe very
rapidly within
30 minutes so we clone the promoter who
covered with luxuries and transferring
other transgenic plants so basically
these transient plants if you treat the
plants with
flattening or non-pathogenic or non-host
bacterial displans like that
and then we musicianize these plants and
then looking for mutants either
hypersensitive or no response
and looking for mutants we name those
mutant as arthous's gene governing
immunity expression as aggie you know we
are
our logo is eggy so this i attract a lot
of undergraduate students and kind of
free labor to do the initial screens
but tensor is a fun project and
so the first the sixth mutant right now
we are characterizing
and are coming from one are you
undergraduate student
it's really fruitful
screen so one mutant i share with you
sort of we kind of understand how this
mutation causes such kind of phenotype
is anyone you could see anyone uh
actually we have two alleles later we
find with my based clone both of them
and finally are the i mean mutated at
the same gene
and so here i showed both of you i mean
both
together you could see the id 1-1
id-1-1-2
the boosters are much higher than
wild-type
and also this mutant
in respond not only to flag 2 but also
other pumps for instance here or faking
all non-pathogenic on the host president
suggesting the mutant
the mutation not only i mean very likely
is not affecting the receptors it's
something happening more downstream
because we know different plants likely
perceived by different receptors we also
performed the rna-seq
analysis and things like the id1 mutant
has further enhanced the flight 22
induced region transcription changes
and this mutant also shows enhanced
disease resistance to
avoidance bacteria
and also strictly this mutant is
extremely resistance to potential
fungi uh
fungal pathogen
however these mutants show an altered
my flex 22 needed immediate mechanics
activation
the loss production also seems like as
similar as white type so suggesting the
mutation occurs either downstream uh are
independent of kindness activation or
loss burst process
so we further performed my base cloning
and
and cloned this gene actually i given
encodes cpr3 which is a putative
ctd phosphor test like protein 3.
so what is the ctd ctd is the
iron polymers 2 c carboxy terminal
domain
it's a rna partners 2 c terminal domain
so we know ra partners 2 is an essential
component regulating all the gene
transcription process right
then this report ii the c terminal
domain consists
of various repeats of conjured hepta
apartheid
so in different organisms this can this
repeats number varies in our blood
system 32
or 30 34 depends on how you classify
these repeats
in terms of conservation and in human uh
things like with small complicated
organism the repeats number increase but
each individual repeats consists this
very conserved uh
seven animal acid pipe type and among
these seven five of lung could be
phosphorylated consisting serine and
tyrosine and throwing residue
so
through many elegant research in east
we know the wave of phosphorylation the
dynamic phosphorylation process on this
individual residue on these multiple
repeats how to treat the transcription
process through the initiation
elimination and termination process
so our
mutant encodes our phosphortes
in east the corresponding homology east
has been shown to de-phosphorylate
certain residues of these habitat
repeats
so then we've
asked
are we examined whether there are any
response for ra par2
in turn upon flecting two treatment so
we cloned the c terminal domain of part
two and put in the cell you could see
strikingly upconflicted to treatment as
early as two minutes
and this ctd our power to see
terminology show rapid mobility shift
later we did more
work demonstrate this mobility shift is
a phosphorylation event
and here this geo is using the phosphor
serving circular 5 7 antibody to detect
the endogenous i call two
phosphorylation status you could see a
conflict 22 treatment
this various residue responding to
fluctuating treatment got
active phosphorylated
then we further asked what kind of
kindness
acting upstream to activate the
phosphorylation of partial cte domain
so it is
we know the second independent protein
kinase can mediate the phosphorylation
activation of the cte
in particular for
the cdkc
cdkc8 family and then we're looking for
the corresponding homologue in our blood
and so which is the closest the members
in cdkc one and two
and again
to our surprise for cdk's particular for
cdkc one upconflict neutral treatment
itself is
a soul migration
shifter again later we did more work and
demonstrated this again is a
phosphorylation event
so indicating the cdkc
one
is responding to select 22 is activated
upon flex and 2 treatment
and
we further asked what's the upstream of
kinase
regulating the ctc activation we know
in the pdi signaling the up
i mean right
below the prr complex is the my
conversion my pioneers cast page we
explore weather mechanics play important
role in activating of the cdkc package
and we use the chinese specific
inhibitor or the magpines phosphates you
could see this inhibitor of the
phosphotix largely reduced
activation of the cdkc
so suggesting maybe a magpies cascade
working upstream of ctc activation
and we know that in our block ccp the
pti signaling magpies 3 6 4 and even 11
play impossible in ppi
pathway and we further test which
specific kindness activated cdkc
here from this immunocomplex kinase i
say you could see my chemistry
could
directly activate ckc and meanwhile we
also see
mypennis3 also acting with cdkc2
and we further performed
my spec analysis identified the
phosphorylation side of kc and you could
see mutate
this phosphorylation site you wipe out
the magnesium activation towards ctc
and as i said the mutant were isolated
in cause of phosphotase and it's a
putative phosphate so only yeast it has
been so this is a functional phosphate
then we further demonstrate actually the
one
in the adoption genome also indeed
period phosphodies activity
and here suits you
when you have the catholic motif of the
phosphates you could wipe out the
phosphorylation of
ctd activated by cdkc upstream
kindness
so
taking this together we demonstrate
through the genetic
approach
we find actually downstream kinase there
is a cdkc complex could be directly
phosphorylated by the magpies uh cascade
and then this cdkc directly phosphory
the importance 2 c terminal domain to
activate the power 2 transcription
arches treating the immune related gene
expression
well this phosphor case we isolated from
the genetic
screen
could be phosphorylate the partial
c-terminal domain to enter
anthropo uh counter-regulate the
part-two activation on the immune gene
activation
so this
so
i spent a few minutes to
explain a little bit from my domestic
project on partner after i moved on to
texas which is a largest april growth
for cotton so
cotton why you why don't race i mean
initially i checked cotton as a crop is
really
cool crop all smiling faced with cotton
fiber everybody love cotton well if you
use cotton research to a similar type of
work search you come up with these
two things everybody said because
it's a very difficult and complex system
and with the extremely longboard cycle
and difficult for transformation only a
few pathways
is able to be transformed
so but meanwhile it's important so i
thought
we should do something with cotton
particularly with local potential
funding supply etc
so
the way we tackle capital cotton
is to develop a transient
isis because so far for cutting most of
research focusing on
genome evolution perspective of fiber
development process there is no any
normal arginine has been isolated from
cotton
and my base cloning is a pain of neck
the genome is 2.5 kb it's a alloy tetra
employee it's very difficult
so the the 29 sigma device one is loss
of function uh by aggravated weak sizing
another one is a game of function as a
through proclass-based transient
transfection so i can escape the
mechanism for weeks but importantly
we found the tre based
virus vector works
perfectly in cotton you could do the
agromedia infiltration 10 day old
seedling and observe very efficient
silencing at the two weeks post
inoculation so
importantly this week's works are on all
different kind of cultural categories so
far we tested the commercial one
and
everything grow in the land
so this really gave us the power to
potentially explore the argent
uh things
so what we uh to explore the knowledge
in culture what we did is we built the
vertices library and then try to perform
similar kind of screen like
a lot of people did in tomato and
tobacco so
inaudible i grow bacteria with the
individual seedling and then swim for
different phenotypes and then we can go
back to sequence the aggro we used to
resolve which gene caused such kind of
phenotype
if this work this is going to really
revolutionize the cotton my base
clothing process is a long person and so
far there is no any succeed in cartoon
yet
and so as a
i mean molecular biologists also we are
not satisfied with only see the
phenotype we want to understand why this
happened right so it is very important
to have a system allow you to
put the gym back to the system to look
at what happened so i adopt uh i mean
modify the procedure for proplus system
so this is really allow you to put the
gene back in two days and then you can
do all sorts of molecular biology to
look at what the protein behavior and to
study the
biochemistry part of the gym function
and the center on these two platforms we
developed
we focusing on cd world which is one of
the devastating diseases in the field
worldwide and particularly with the v1
and back one they are prr type of like a
festival type of receptor like kinase
examining the signal transduction in
this cascade and more recently we are
also
doing collaboration work with adam for
bacterial blight looking for tail
targets
mediating either resistance or
susceptibility and another perspective
is root rot root rot is very badly in
texas and so we're developing the
relations in a good part so allow us to
silence the gene the root to examine the
requirement mediating root rot another
thing is the drug tolerance the reason i
think the drug is initially charged is
one of the easiest treated to do we just
do inoculation and stop water
and then go back
so
although i mean the waste kind of
successful in terms of isolating two
components although they are in the
non-ada pathway but there is no
molecular link seems like we are
building some
something quite interesting
one of my kind is serving as director
substitute of synergy kindness and
smurkiness also kind of directly false
foreign kindness which is something
we don't know in the previous knowledge
and these two pathways work
independently in the downstream of
dehydration pathway so we are trying to
figure out the exact mechanism why we
thought they are connected
genetically also independent so
share a little bit the
preliminary result we did together with
adam it's a really fun project
and so the tau in fact
actually for cotton bacterial variety is
a sibling disease
so
through many years of research we know
the causal agent sentiments
the main pathogenicity factor is
mediated by type three factors and among
those types three factors a larger group
are telling factors and we know the tail
effector function like a transcription
factor it carries the nuclear
localization activation domain and also
has a unique dna binding specificity
repeats those repeat dictating the
recognition specificity of the host
target sequence
so through adam's research we know that
we can potentially predict
the
recognition side of the individual
tail effectors
so then we choose two typical uh
subscribe hotel in factor one is avr b6
which
when uh from important is one of the
wealth
characterized in terms of the
corresponding resistance low side
and another one is pth and it's the
major burdens determined in sense motors
so we clone those individual effectors
espresso in the cotton
proplant cell and then perform the
transcriptome analysis of
upper regulated or downregulated genes
by these two tests
and then working together with atoms to
predict the potential
target gene among those elderly
expression transcript
and then we further confirm those
transcription changes
and then perform a serious experiment in
terms of
the
transactivation essay and also
next step is to perform last skill can
look for radius as they are detailed as
to examine the requirement of
those candidate gene mediating
six-minute hr resistance and pth
immediate susceptibility so hopefully
through this
we can
i mean provide the information what kind
of host target
mediated by these avr or pth
factors from sensor owners
so with that i would like to thank folks
that work in the lab
and also wonderful collaborators a lot
of bio informatics work together with
john jim clay here at the bti and adam
of course and
several other peoples in various
institutions those are funding agencies
i'm sorry to give such long talks and
supposed to stop five minutes early so
now i'm happy to take any questions with
your help
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu